today on the matt welsh show violent
insurrectionists descend this time on
louisville
in response to the grand jury decision
the brianna taylor case
but almost everything blm has said about
the shooting of brianna taylor is a lie
not that the truth matters to them of
course but we'll talk about what the
truth is
uh in this case today also five
headlines including the left fretting
that donald trump won't submit to a
peaceful transfer of power that's a
pretty rich
charge coming from them as they continue
to burn down our cities
and in our daily cancellation i will
cancel the cdc for trying to cancel
halloween i won't let them do it i won't
let them get away with it
all of that coming up but first let's
talk about eero you know these days your
house isn't just your house it's a
it's an office it's a school my house is
also a lunatic asylum most of the time
with four kids running around
kind of a zoo of sorts as well a war
zone a toxic waste dump at least in my
son's room
a lot going on and that's why i need and
you need also in your home i'm sure
solid wi-fi
in the whole house which is where euro
comes in euro an amazon company
covers your whole home with fast
reliable wi-fi inside and out
uh rooms with with bad to no wi-fi
dropouts on your patio eero makes
every square foot of your home usable by
eliminating poor coverage in dead spots
you'll have a consistently strong signal
wherever you need it uh you know we're
asking a lot of our of our wi-fi i think
euro can help yours do more that's what
it's done for me go to eero.com
walsh enter codewall should check out to
get free next day shipping with your
order that's e-e-r-o-dot-com
walsh codewalsh at checkout to get your
euro delivered with free next day
shipping eero.com
walsh code walsh okay well it's being
said that
rioting broke out in louisville over the
grand jury's decision the brianna taylor
case but
that's wrong on two levels for one the
chaos in louisville
as in so many other cities across the
country is funded and organized
moments after the grand jury returned
only three counts of wanton endangerment
against one officer for firing shots
that went into a neighbor's apartment
but no charges for taylor's death
u-hauls packed with pre-made signs and
riot shields were already on the scene
being unloaded now it's clear that
there's there's orchestration and
planning involved
also these are not mere riots these are
violent uprisings with the clear and
often stated goal
of destabilizing the government and
burning down the system
in other words it's insurrection so
rather than riots breaking out this was
another
campaign of insurrection being carried
out
and the distinction is important it's
also important
though not relevant to the
insurrectionists that the
narrative surrounding the brianna taylor
case advanced by blm
and antifa and their allies in the media
has proven to be almost
entirely false the narrative in these
high-profile police shootings
is always false of course the only
question is one of degree just how wrong
will it turn out to be
in nearly all of the high profile cases
over the past few months especially
that answer has generally varied between
extremely
and incredibly for example the narrative
around the jacob blake
uh shooting in kenosha claimed that he
was unarmed
and shot by cops while trying to get
into his car after stopping to break up
a fight
in reality he was harassing his alleged
rape victim was armed with a knife
was reaching into his ex-girlfriend's
car which he was allegedly trying to
steal
when the officer fired in the shooting
of dion k in dc we were at first told
that kaye
was an unarmed child shot in the back as
it turns out he was an adult a known
gang member and was shot in the chest
while running towards officers with his
gun drawn the case of ricardo munoz in
lancaster activists told us that he was
a
mentally disabled person randomly gunned
down outside his mother's house
some even said there were some blm
people online saying he was
an autistic child murdered by the cops
in reality munoz was 27 years old
was shot because he chased after a
police officer while wielding a large
knife
blm has gotten almost every fact of
every case
wrong going all the way back to michael
brown in 2014 he was claimed to have
been murdered with his hands up while
begging for his life
forensic evidence eyewitness reports
eventually confirmed that he was
actually shot
while assaulting a police officer and
trying to steal his weapon and this
after he had assaulted a store clerk and
committed a robbery so what about
brianna taylor
now initially it was reported that
police burst into the wrong apartment
without knocking during a botched drug
raid
and murdered taylor while she was asleep
that would be indefensible if it was
true but once again
it wasn't as kentucky attorney general
daniel cameron
explained in his press conference on
wednesday officers were serving a
legal warrant at the right location
and they did knock before entering an
independent witness corroborates that
they announced and identified themselves
upon entering the residents brianna's
taylor brianna teller's boyfriend
kenneth walker
opened fired on officers when police
returned fire briana taylor was hit and
killed
here's a cameron at the press conference
explaining some of this
evidence shows that officers both
knocked
and announced their presence at the
apartment
the officers statements about their
announcement are corroborated
by an independent witness who was near
in a proximity to apartment four
in other words the warrant was not
served
as a no knock warrant when officers were
unable to get anyone to answer or open
the door
to apartment 4 the decision was made
to breach the door after breaching the
door
sergeant mattingly was the first and
only officer
to enter the residence sergeant
mattingly identified
two individuals standing beside one
another at the end of the hall
a male and a female in his statement
he says that the male was holding a gun
arms extended
in a shooting stance sergeant mattingly
saw the man's gun fire heard a boom
and immediately knew he was shot as a
result of feeling heat
in his upper thigh kenneth walker
fired the shot that hit sergeant
mattingly and there is no evidence to
support that sergeant mattingly
was hit by friendly fire from other
officers
now we should mention a warrant was
issued for taylor's apartment
because there was reason to suspect that
taylor or at least her apartment
was in some way involved in her criminal
ex-boyfriend's drug
drug enterprise as court documents show
taylor's car was spotted multiple times
outside of a known drug house that was
under surveillance by law enforcement
taylor is on tape reportedly referring
to the drug house
while speaking to her then boyfriend
while he was in jail
in 2016 the body of a murder victim was
allegedly found in a car rented by
taylor which she said she had lent to
her boyfriend
shortly after her death the ex-boyfriend
was again recorded in jailhouse phone
conversations claiming that taylor was
quote handling his money
the point is that the warrant was issued
for entirely valid reasons
the cops executed it according to the
law
following all the proper protocols only
opened fire after walker had begun
shooting at them
there is no basis for calling this a
murder much less a racist murder by
agents of white supremacy
it's a tragic accident a catastrophic
confluence of events many other terms
can be used to describe it
but the fact remains that officers were
serving a lawful warrant
acting within the bounds of the law and
responding with lethal force
to the lethal force being used against
them
as usual those accusing the officers of
criminal conduct have not bothered to
explain
what they might have done differently
should they have not
obtained the warrant for the apartment
in the first place despite having
credible reason to believe that it had
ties to drug
trafficking should they not have
executed the warrant should they not
have
or should they have waited outside for
someone to come to the door and if the
residents
refused to answer then just pack up and
go home
or should they have not returned fire
once once they were fired upon
instead you know diving to the floor or
hiding behind furniture hoping the
assailant stops before a bullet
hits one of them in the face now blm
militants if they were being honest
would actually answer
yes to all of those questions they've
made it clear that their
problem with the police is that the
police exist
anything the police do therefore is
wrong
for the simple fact the police are the
ones doing it for blm and its allies the
fight against police brutality is a
fight against policing itself
all law enforcement is brutality in
their minds
and anybody who dies at the hands of
police any black person anyway
has been murdered no matter what
regardless of context
this is the radicalism that holds our
cities hostage
the madness to which we are all supposed
to bow
it dresses itself in the garb of racial
justice it carries signs that say things
like equality
but this is all a decidedly unconvincing
disguise
for their radical assault on law and
order and civilization itself
and that's what's happening and now it's
happening in louisville
let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know one of our uh one of our really
loyal sponsors and supporters of the
show is wise company uh we've been
with working with them for a long time
well now they've changed their name
uh you know about wise company now they
are ready wise
and they've got a whole bunch of they've
expanded their their their their catalog
their
products that are available now we know
they have emergency meals
they've got freeze-dried fruits and
vegetables for convenient on-the-go
nutrition
but now they also have adventure meals
for hiking camping other outdoor
activities
and you know i know for me my experience
with the with ready wise
is just a peace of mind especially in in
these days
and these uh shall we call them
uncertain times
to use the media phrase that we hear so
often uh
it and there is a lot of uncertainty so
i feel some peace of mind just knowing
that i've got
these meals and i'm prepared for an
emergency if it uh if it should ever
happen
ready wise makes being prepared simple
and affordable or you can order online
you can have nutritious meals shipped
directly to your doorstep and when
preparing our meals
all you need to need is just four cups
of water now the water
doesn't even need to be hot so it's very
easy for you you simply pour the food
into water you stir and cover after
about 15 minutes the meal is ready
some meals can even be prepared directly
in the pouch eliminating the need for
additional um
supplies i've tried some of these meals
even though you know i've got the
adventure meals i've also got the the
ones for an emergency
just i've tried them myself and i can
say that uh you can tell
that there's a lot of crafting that goes
into this um
and they are they're good they taste
good even though they're for emergencies
this week my listener can get free
shipping my listeners can get uh free
shipping at readywise.com when entering
walsh at checkout or by calling
855-475-3089
wise has a 90 day no questions asked
return policy so there's no risk taking
the initiative to get yourself and your
family prepared today
that's readywise r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e
dot com promo code walsh to get free
shipping today
all right yeah you may have heard that i
just said my listener can get free
shipping
the one you know why not look let's be
honest i have two
so my one listener the other one also
both of you guys can get free shipping
uh with ready wise okay speaking of the
insurrection
two louisville police officers at least
at least two were shot
by a blm militant last night uh the
violence
wasn't just in louisville in portland
they were throwing molotov cocktails as
you can see here
somebody well there we go just
peacefully firebombing the cops there
in seattle here they are beating a cop
over the head with a metal bat
peacefully of course um this of course
has been
going on in those two cities for months
literally months
which is why those mayors should be in
prison they should be forcibly deposed
and thrown in prison
they have abdicated their
responsibilities and and they have to be
dealt with
wait until after the election if that's
what you need to do but then
this this cannot be allowed to continue
this this is this is not this goes way
beyond politics
but that's portland and seattle back to
louisville where the riots the
insurrection was very violent
and it involved the attempted murder of
at least two cops here's how reuters
described it by the way
they said demonstrations of louisville
wore on past nightfall in defiance of a
9pm curfew
and remained mostly peaceful until
several gunshots rang out
in the midst of a skirmish between
protesters and heavily armed police
mostly peaceful until they tried to blow
the brains out of two cops
yes well you know things are always
peaceful until they aren't
right the the normandy landings were
peaceful until the shooting started
uh the town of sharpsburg was was quaint
and quiet and peaceful until the battle
of
antietam commenced that's how it works
abc 11 had a different spin they said um
louisville officer shot but unclear if
tied to protests
yes kind of reminds me of a
titanic passenger drowns but unclear if
tied to ship
sinking same same general idea now
democratic governor andy beshear in
kentucky
spoke last night about the shooting of
the police officers and here's what he
had to say
hi everyone i know that with the events
of today
many people are feeling powerful
emotions
whether that's frustration anger
concern and many people have been
out on the streets especially in
louisville tonight giving voice
to those emotions but sadly we have seen
at least one individual turn
what were non-violent ways of expressing
ourselves
into the shooting of at least two law
enforcement officers
we know that the answer to violence is
never violence
and we are thinking about those two
officers
and their families tonight so i'm asking
everybody please
go home go home tonight
there will be many times over the coming
days where there will be an
opportunity to be heard and so many
people
are listening right now as your governor
i've promised to listen but let's make
sure we don't see any more violence
tonight and let's make sure that we find
ways of expressing ourselves moving
forward
where your point and other people's
points are made
and that hopefully we can not just
listen but we can hear
everybody out there stay safe we care
about each and every one of you
good night yeah that's what we call bare
minimum weak pathetic
obviously he had to say something he
couldn't just completely ignore as much
as he probably would have liked to
the shooting of two of his police
officers but that that's about as
weak as a denunciation goes and keep in
mind now
if i if i didn't know any better and i
didn't know the context
um and i was just listening to the tone
in in the way this is approached i would
think that he was
talking about i don't know some people
spray painting
just just some just some petty vandalism
or something this is the attempted
murder of two police
officers during violent riots and this
is how bashir approaches it
um and that is and even that he's gonna
get flack from the left for that
as pathetic and weak as it was number
two um
well what's what's the media and the
left freaking out about today
not the violent revolution happening in
our streets they love that
not the cops who were shot bombed beaten
last night
they're in favor of that too no instead
it's this
uh this is what they're worried about
this is what trump said during a press
conference and we are supposed to be
very very concerned
and scared and worried about this listen
when loser draw in this election will
you commit here today for a peaceful
trans referral of power after the
election
and there has been rioting in louisville
there's been rioting in many cities
across this country
red and your so-called red and blue
states will you commit to making sure
that there is a peaceful transferal of
power
after the election well we're gonna have
to see what happens you know that i've
been complaining very strongly about
the ballots and the ballots are a
disaster and
but people are rioting do you commit to
making sure that there's a peaceful
transfer
we want to have get rid of the ballots
and you'll have a very trans we'll have
a very peaceful
there won't be a transfer frankly
there'll be a continuation
the ballots are out of control you know
it and you know who knows it better than
anybody else the democrats know it
better than anybody else go ahead
oh no he's he's not committing to the
peaceful transfer of power
he's going to refuse he's going to
barricade himself in the white house and
refuse to come out
he's going to stage a military coup
right yeah that's a real concern
first of all listen to the question
again
trump was asked if he would commit to
transfer of power
win lose or draw so they were trying to
get him to
agree to transferring power even if he
wins
very stupid question and trump's answer
to it was fine the only criticism i
would have the only one
is that i think he should have concluded
his answer by
politely inviting that reporter to kiss
his ass
that i think that would have been that's
a polite thing to do and so i would have
preferred that but
other than that it was a fine answer um
and and also it's it's
it's yeah if if you want to
misunderstand
the point on purpose than you always can
of course
if you're a dishonest person but
it's it's clear what trump is getting at
is is
like i'm not if i actually lose
okay but he's there there are concerns
that
uh the story will be that he lost even
though he didn't
okay he's worried about the election
being stolen from him
biden and the democrats are saying the
exact same sorts of things
so if you have a problem with that kind
of rhetoric it is really on both sides
this is not a what about both this is
real this is both sides both sides
are saying this um
so whatever criticism you have of that
it it applies across the board
but also i mean the main point is this
you just cannot pretend
or you can pretend all you want but you
cannot be taken seriously in pretending
that you
care about a peaceful transfer of power
while your people
are currently as we speak in the process
of burning down cities
shooting cops beating cops firebombing
cops okay
you cannot months and months of this
and now you're pretending that you care
about a peaceful transfer but it's too
late for a peaceful transfer of power
we are already in the midst of of in
decidedly non-peaceful um
time time in our country and that is all
on the left
peaceful transfer of power yes yes i'm
very concerned about the peaceful
transfer of power
he thought to himself as he threw a
molotov cocktail at police
and not only that by the way but they're
they've also they're out openly
promising to burn it all down
burn the system down if uh if
you know if trump is re-elected so
yes but they're concerned about peaceful
transfer power sure
number three president trump yesterday
announced an executive order um let's
listen to this
i will always protect the vital role of
religion and prayer in american society
and i will always defend the sacred
right to life
today i am announcing that i will be
signing the born alive executive order
to ensure that all precious babies born
alive no matter
their circumstances receive the medical
care that they deserve
this is our sacrosanct moral duty
we are also increasing federal funding
for the neonatal research
to ensure that every child has the very
best chance to thrive and to grow
so the daily wire reports that this is
this this order is expected to mirror
the born alive abortion survivors
protection act
which states that a healthcare protect
practitioner who's present must exercise
the same degree of care
as reasonably provided to another child
born alive at the same gestational age
and to immediately admit the child to a
hospital the bill also requires a health
care practitioner or other employee
to immediately report any failure to
comply with this requirement to law
enforcement
a person who violates this requirement
is subject to criminal penalties a fine
up to five years in prison or both
um additionally an individual who
intentionally kills or attempts to kill
a child born alive is subject to
prosecution for murder and that's all of
that is great that's exactly what it
should be
any sane person agrees with this um
this this is this is an issue that
republicans and conservatives should be
talking about
trump is right to act on it and um yeah
let the left go out as they are now and
as they will continue to
and openly advocate for infanticide but
remember again
totally peaceful a peaceful infanticide
number four um let's get to some
important news here uh you look at this
picture right here that's a giant rat
pulled out of a sewer true story okay
the new york post has the story it says
mexico city cleanup crews um lived
everybody
everybody's worst nightmare on september
18th when they discovered what looked
like a monster drowned
rat while dredging the cereals the the
cereals
the sewers the buick sized rodent was
part of a
of 20 to 22 tons of litter the workers
had removed from the city's drainage
tunnels following heavy rains
during the unsavory gig the workers
reportedly turned a corner
and encountered what they described as a
giant rat which sat hunched over and
sported incredibly realistic fur
as it turns out the vermin was actually
a halloween prop
that's disappointing that had been
washed out of its warehouse by the storm
i mean it was unlikely but i was really
rooting for this to be real
um you know choose the form of your
destructor kind of thing
and uh and if if we have to have the
apocalypse then
i think an apocalypse at the hands of
oversized rats would be
i don't know how enjoyable it would be
but would certainly be appropriate
a woman named evelyn lopez has since
come forward to claim
to claim the rat which she reportedly
created from scratch for halloween
lopez said it had gone missing years ago
during a torrential downpour
and no one could help her retrieve it
so it's been she couldn't find that huge
thing for years
and now she finally has found it well
i'm glad for their reunion
number five um this couldn't come soon
enough racism has finally been solved
it's over folks you can go home uncle
ben's the rice brand has announced that
it will take the
word uncle off of its product and also
remove the picture of a black man from
the product
in order to combat racism you understand
so they they made this big announcement
on their website you could see here
ben's original that's the new name we've
listened we've learned we're changing
it says over the last several weeks we
have listened to thousands of consumers
our own associates and other
stakeholders from around the world
we understand the inequities that were
associated with the name and face of the
uncle ben's brand
that what what inequities were
associated with the name of a box of
rice
and so blah blah blah they decided to
change it
this of course just doesn't make any
sense at all
how how are we helping to solve racism
by taking a black man's face off
of the packaging how was that
i thought i thought so
we we have like both strategies
happening here
because on one hand we're told we need
more representation and uh
you know racial minorities need to be
more visible and
that's why they're doing apparently they
announced they're going to do uh they're
doing a friend's remake with an
all-black cast and so there's a lot of
that sort of thing going on
and we're going to combat racism that
way
but we're also going to combat it by
with less visibility by
by taking you know black faces off of
packaging and that sort of thing doesn't
really make a lot of sense to me
all right we're going to get to our
daily cancellation in just a second but
before we do um you know i've been
telling you for a long time about
our sponsors vincero i'm wearing one of
the watches right now a watch should be
something you look forward to putting on
every day i know i do and that's exactly
how i feel about my venture watches
ventura was dedicated to the craft they
put the time and effort into crafting
timepieces
so you can wear them day after day the
guys on their team
they sent over some watches and i've
enjoyed watching
wearing them regularly with vincero
there's no brand name market no big
big time price tags their promise to you
is really simple
solid well-made product that you will
enjoy wearing
and during this time they're continuing
to do right by their buyers these guys
they know how important it is
to shop from brands that you can trust
so you can check out their watches just
go to venturawatches.com
walsh to get access to their exclusive
discount
video offers free shipping uh 30 day
returns
guarantees for your watches for two
years and that's why you can go look at
the reviews i've got 22
000 5 star reviews and that's what i
trust really
i mean 22 000 people all agreeing they
can't be wrong
take advantage of 20 off everything on
their website material has styles for
men and women as well as accessories
wallets bracelets extra straps
sunglasses
all of that incredible quality like i
said these are timepieces you will enjoy
wearing every single day if you don't
ventura will make it right that's their
promise if you don't love it
they will make it right by you but you
will love it trust me
go shop vincero the deal really is too
good to pass up go to v-i-n-c-e-r-o
watches dot com forward slash walsh do
not pay full price on these beautiful
timepieces take advantage of our
exclusive discount and get up to 25
or 20 off your entire order um
all right let's get to our daily
cancellation hey by the way you know we
there are so many ways you can enjoy the
podcast you could watch it listen
to it deli wire members can now also
enjoy our shows on apple tv and roku so
members can enjoy all the visual
elements of this podcast and our other
shows on your big screen
either live or on demand find the daily
wire app on
apple tv or roku and you could download
today so i wanted to tell you about that
as well now today for our daily
cancellation we're going to cancel the
cdc
uh it's a long past time for the cdc to
face its cancellation
there have been many straws straining
this particular camel's back
the straw that finally broke it is this
as you can see the center for disease
control has a whole page on its website
giving guidance on holiday celebrations
because of course in a free country the
first thing a citizen ought to do before
observing a holiday is check with a
public health organization
and consult a series of federal agencies
before deciding how to celebrate it
this is why in my household you know our
tradition on christmas morning is that
we all wake up early in our
early in the morning in our christmas
jammies yes i have christmas jammies and
yes i do call them jammies what of it
and we all wake up we go downstairs we
gather around the christmas tree
and then we submit an application to the
department of health and human services
requesting a waiver that will permit us
to open presents and usually it only
takes about two to three business days
to come through
and the kids really enjoy it it's a lot
of fun now
in any case here's the cdc um and
this is this is them explaining their
guidelines it says as many people in the
united states begin to plan for fall and
winter holiday celebrations
cdc offers the following considerations
to help protect individuals their
families friends and communities from
coven 19.
these are considerations meant to
supplement not replace
any state local territorial or tribal
health and safety laws rules and
regulations with
which holiday gatherings must comply
when planning to host a holiday
celebration you should assess
current covenant 19 levels in your
community to determine whether to
postpone cancel or limit the number of
attendees
then it proceeds to give guidance on all
fall holidays
and it lists those holidays as rosh
hashanah yom kippur
halloween uh daya de los muertos
navratri diwali and thanksgiving so i'll
have to consult their diwali guidelines
later but
here's what it says for halloween uh it
says avoid these
higher risk activities to help prevent
the spread of the virus that causes
covet 19
says um and then here are the high risk
activities participating in traditional
trick-or-treating where
treats are handed to children who go
door-to-door having trunk or treat where
treats are handed out from trunks of
cars lined up in large parking lots
attending crowded costume parties held
indoors going to an indoor haunted house
where people may be
crowded together and screaming going on
hayrides or tractor rides with people
who
are not in your household using alcohol
or drugs which can cloud judgment and
increase risky behaviors
traveling to a rural fall festival that
is not in your community if you live in
an area community
an area with community spread of
covenant 19 so those are the things that
you must avoid according to your public
health overlords
but not to worry they do provide some
low
risk safe alternatives these low-risk
activities
include carving or decorating pumpkins
with members of your household and
displaying them
carving or decorating pumpkins outside
at a safe distance with neighbors or
friends
decorating your house apartment or
living space
doing a halloween scavenger hunt where
children are given lists of halloween
themed things to look for while they
walk outdoors from house to house
admiring halloween decorations at a
distance
having a virtual halloween costume
contest
having a halloween movie night with
people you live with
having a scavenger hunt style trick or
treat search with your household members
in or around your home rather than going
house to house
okay yes decorate your home for a
festive halloween party
and then invite no one over just sit
there in your living room
alone staring at the wall weeping
quietly while gorging yourself on fun
size snickers or
as i like to call it a normal tuesday
night now
these these suggestions are are helpful
from the cdc but i'm afraid they may be
giving us
too much latitude some of these
activities seem very risky in fact like
carving a pumpkin there's the obvious
danger that the knife might slip you
might disembowel yourself accidentally i
have two cousins and an uncle who all
died that way
it was a bloody night which you know it
wasn't such a bad thing i guess given
that it was halloween
but also when when you go outside to
place your pumpkin on the porch
can you be sure that at the same moment
your neighbor might not be walking to
his car across the street and then
cough and a stiff breeze might carry the
coveted virus directly into your
nostrils
you know you might say well then i'll
wear a mask well of course you will but
then the virus might enter through your
eyes and then you say well then i'll
wear a face shield
okay fine but the virus might go into
your ears or it might attach yourself to
your clothes and then later that night
while you're getting changed for bed it
might leap into any number of exposed
orifices
now the risk of any of this happening is
somewhere in the neighborhood of like
point zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero
zero zero zero zero zero one percent but
it's not
non-existent there is some risk
and what we've learned in recent months
is that we simply cannot afford to take
any risk of any kind at all ever
period unless of course you are not a
lunatic
and you prefer to actually still live a
human life you selfish bastard
and maybe you've come to terms with the
fact that you're mortal and
uh risk will always be there and
eventually you will die probably not of
covet but of something
so hiding in your home huddled under
your blanket
is not only a pathetic and dreary
existence but ultimately futile
you're gonna die anyway if that's the
case
then you will go out and still trick or
treat because quite obviously
you know in all seriousness
trick-or-treating is not high risk at
all
you're outside kids are the ones doing
it
they aren't likely to contract or spread
the virus anyway they're already wearing
many of the masks and gloves for the
costumes
they aren't bunched together in tight
groups their interactions with people
answering the door are brief
if this is high risk then literally
anything is
which brings us back to huddling in our
homes under the blankets
what i can say is high risk or not
i will be out with my kids
trick-or-treating on halloween
so you better answer your damned door
because we're coming
and if you don't answer we might throw a
brick through the window
though we would only be doing that of
course for racial justice and peace
and because we're mad you didn't give us
any candy
which i'm increasingly convinced is also
the motivation behind many of these
rioters
they're just mad that we're not giving
them candy
uh but the cdc is uh is cancelled
finally for all of that
and halloween they say halloween is
cancelled i say
it's a go congratulations you're welcome
i'll talk to you tomorrow have a great
day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching
and the moon has turned to blood but on
the andrew clavin show that's where the
fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton